THE SUMMIT'S SIGNIFICANTS COMING
UP.
FIRST UP THOUGH, WE START WITH
THE URGENT RESCUE MISSION IN
PAKISTAN TO BRING FOUR PEOPLE
TRAPPED IN A CHAIR LIFT TO
SAFETY.
PAKISTAN'S SPECIAL SERVICES
GROUP HAVE RESCUED FOUR CHILDREN
SO FAR, TWO KIDS AND TWO ADULTS
REMAIN DANGLING IN THIS CHAIR
LIFT.
THEY HAVE BEEN TRAPPED FOR HOURS
AFTER A CABLE SNAPPED 274
MEETERS IN THE AIR.
THE CHILDREN AGES 10 TO 15 WERE
ON THEIR WAY TO SCHOOL.
WE ARE JOINED NOW FROM
ISLAMABAD.
AND ARE WE ANY CLOSER AT THIS
POINT TO RESCUING THOSE WHO ARE
STILL TRAPPED, SOFIA?
>> WELL, BECKY, WHILE IT HAS
BEEN GREAT NEWS THAT THOSE FOUR
KIDS HAVE BEEN RESCUED, THERE IS
A SITUATION THAT BECAUSE IT'S
NOW NIGHT FALL AND THE REMOTE
PART OF NORTH WESTERN PAKISTAN,
THE HELICOPTER RESCUE OPERATION
HAS HAD TO BE PAUSED BECAUSE
THERE IS JUST TOO MUCH DARKNESS
THERE FOR THAT TO CONTINUE.
SO THERE ARE EFFORTS BEING MADE
BY THE COMMANDERS ON THE GROUND
AS WELL AS BY LOCALS TO KIND OF
REACH THAT CABLE CAR THAT IS
SUSPENDED ABOUT 900 FEET ABOVE
GROUND.
AND THIS HAS HAD THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY FIXATED FOR MORE THAN
TEN HOURS.
THESE KIDS WERE ON THEIR WAY TO
SCHOOL AT ABOUT 8:30 THIS
MORNING LOCAL TIME.
THEY WERE COMMUTING BETWEEN TWO
VALLEYS.
THEIR SCHOOL WAS ON ONE SIDE,
THEIR VILLAGE WAS ON ANOTHER,
WHEN THIS HAPPENED.
ONE CABLE SNAPPED, THERE WERE
ALREADY ISSUES REGARDING THE
RESCUE SITUATION BECAUSE OF THE
FACT THAT THE HELI'S BLADES WERE
CAUSING WINDS WHICH WERE CAUSING
THAT ONE CABLE THAT WAS HOLDING
UP THAT CABLE CAR A LOT OF TO
MOVE VERY FREQUENTLY.
SO AGAIN, THOSE CHILDREN WERE
NAUSEATED.
THEY DROPPED, IN THE COMMANDOS
DROPPED IN ANTINAUSEA MEDS WE
WERE TOLD BY ONE OF THE
CHILDREN, SPEAKING TO LOCAL
MEDIA FROM HIS PHONE.
THAT TWO OF THE CHILDREN HAD
VOMITED.
ANOTHER TWO WERE IN AND OUT OF
CONSCIOUSNESS.
YOU HAVE TO REALIZE THIS IS A
CONGESTED CAGE-LIKE CONTRAPTION
WHICH IS SUSPENDED MID AIR AND
CONSTANTLY MOVING BY THE WINDS,
SO IT IS NOW COMPLETELY NIGHT
FALL IN THAT AREA.
IT IS STILL VERY OMINOUS BUT
THERE IS A LOT OF HOPE IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT THIS RESCUE
OPERATION WILL BE SUK
SECRETARY-- SUCCESSFUL.
BECKY?
>> AND WE ARE ALL PRAYING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE STILL TRAPPED.
WHAT HAVE LOCAL AUTHORITIES SAID
ABOUT THE INCIDENT?
>> WHAT WE DO KNOW FROM PEOPLE
ON THE GROUND IS, IS THAT THERE
IS A LOT OF SUPPORT FOR THE
COMMANDOS THAT ARE THERE ON THE
GROUND.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE GATHERED THERE.
WE ARE BEING TOLD THAT AGAIN
WHILE THE RESCUE OPERATION BY
HELICOPTER HAS STOPPED, THEY'RE
TRYING TO EFFORT ROACHES, THERE
IS A LOT OF LOCAL KNOWLEDGE
THERE BECAUSE THIS IS A